breaking news from the washington post
biden stimulus showers money on
americans
sharply cutting poverty and favoring
individuals
over businesses i think that north
korean state tv would
probably blush at that headline and
maybe maybe my memory is going maybe i'm
becoming a little slow
like joe biden but as i recall when
donald trump did exactly the same thing
the coverage was just a little bit
different democracy dies in darkness i'm
michael knowles this michael knowles
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
coming from friday is from eric gomez
who says that the p
in saki is silent it's the same with the
p
in president biden this is very true you
have white house press secretary jenn
saki and you have white house resident
joe biden
who is just sort of being scooted along
in the hallways from the tv
room to the dining room back to bed for
about i don't know six o'clock at night
or so
while our elite establishment
runs the country not a very safe time
for our traditions and liberties you
know speaking of safety you gotta go
check out lifelock
with the tax deadline approaching it's
important to take steps to avoid being a
victim of tax scams
cyber criminals have used social
security numbers to file fake returns in
an attempt to steal refunds
file early be aware of suspicious
activities related to your return
and find out if you're eligible to apply
for an irs identity protection pin
very important to understand how cyber
crime and identity theft are affecting
our lives every day
we put our information at risk on the
internet in an instant
a cyber criminal could harm what's yours
your finances and your credit
good thing there's lifelock lifelock
helps detect a wide range of identity
threats like your social security number
for sale on the dark web
i know what you're thinking you're
thinking no one's after my data no one's
after my identity
i used to think that way it's just not
true
no one can prevent all identity theft or
monitor
all transactions at all businesses but
you can keep what's yours with lifelock
identity theft
protection join now and save up to 25
percent off your first year by going to
lifelock.com
knowles that is lifelock.com knowles
knwles for 25
off same newspaper same
laws same policy
just stimulus for americans from the
coronavirus
but different political party in power
so when it's joe biden
the headline from the washington post is
biden stimulus showers money on
americans sharply cutting poverty and
favoring individuals
over businesses when that president is
donald trump
the headline in the washington post is
in unprecedented move
treasury orders trump's name printed
on stimulus checks
um one of those seems more favorable
than the other that's not it though
washington post also
when trump was signing coveted relief
quote
trump signs two trillion dollar
coronavirus bill into law
as companies and households brace for
more
economic pain
brace for pain money will be
showered over you cutting poverty and
favoring individuals
brace for pain same law
same newspaper is it any wonder
that people do not trust our
established elites when people question
the coronavirus policies for instance
when people question certain mandates
on the vaccine talk perhaps of mandates
on the on the vaccine certainly existing
mandates
on the masks on social distancing
are people really so crazy to question
the wisdom of our benevolent bettors
when people say hmm maybe there were
some irregularities in the election
and then our elites just come down as
they say there was absolutely nothing
wrong we would never lie to you
everything is totally hunky-dory even
though we changed
uh very important election integrity
measures right before the 2020 election
is it any wonder that people might not
believe those elites you know
the the governor of mississippi tate
reeves
has been really really impressive uh of
late
and tate reeves goes on jake tapper's
show
and wants to talk about reopening
mississippi where their focus is
but jake tapper wants to get one thing
clear first are you willing to say are
you willing to go on record and say
that there was absolutely nothing
suspect whatsoever
not even a jot or tittle with the 2020
presidential election
former president trump and his allies
have now for months and months continue
to spread
the false and dangerous lie that the
election was stolen you were not
part of that campaign but i want to ask
you a simple yes or no question because
your answer a few weeks ago to a
colleague kind of raise my eyebrows
do you accept that joe biden is the
legitimate lawfully accepted
lawfully elected president of the united
states
president biden is the president of the
united states
was he legitimate
was he was this the most legitimate
election ever with the most
integrity and there's absolutely no
questions whatsoever will you say it
will you say it
goodness gracious it is so difficult
to put up with watching jake tapper it's
so hard to do it i only do it for you
because i know that i have to relate
these things to you dear listener
which is why i will do it but otherwise
i would never watch this man
who is raising this question
i think in the minds of some other
people who are skeptical of our elites
which is
if this is the most totally hunky-dory
election of all time and there were no
questions whatsoever anywhere even on
the smallest scale
of fraud or irregularities or illegal
election procedures
all of which we've detailed pretty
regularly on this show
if that's the case why is it so
important to you jake tapper
that this governor says exactly what you
want him to say
if it's so clear if it's so obvious that
there were no questions whatsoever
why does every republican politician
have to repeat this kind of mantra the
2020 election was totally perfect and
there were no questions
why do we have to keep repeating that ad
nauseam why do you need to
d platform anybody that in any way
suggests that huh
maybe it was a little weird that the
pennsylvania election officials
violated their state constitution with
the mail-in votes
why why are we not allowed to say that
why is the governor of mississippi not
allowed to raise these sorts of
questions on the air
is it maybe because you're a little
insecure about the 2020 election
not saying that the result in the end
was different than it would have been
i'm just saying
it is undeniable that the election
was highly irregular that the the
processes for the election were upended
in the days and weeks before
that election integrity measures were
stripped away that it was the strangest
election in our lifetimes
why aren't we allowed to say that
governor
reeves continues in our state we do not
allow mail in voting and the reason we
don't allow mail in voting is because we
don't think
um that it we think that it allows for
lots of opportunities for fraud and
other things
and i don't think melon voting should be
allowed in other states around the
nation but president biden is the
newly elected president and we're going
to do everything we can to work with him
to help the citizens of mississippi even
that is not enough for jake tapper he
keeps going back he's like yeah but say
that biden's great say he's awesome say
the election
was totally perfect but what the
governor is saying here is absolutely
right
mail-in voting is a direct threat to our
democracy which dies in darkness i am
reliably informed by the washington post
and we should not have widespread mail
in voting
barack obama was saying that not so long
ago everybody agreed with that it's just
obvious but now we're not allowed to say
obvious things because this power grab
has become so
transparent turning from good governors
like the governor of mississippi
to bad governors like andrew cuomo cuomo
is
really really in hot water right now
two more women have come forward i think
the number now is up to five
some of these claims are fairly dubious
i actually want to be fair to cuomo
some seem a little vague
okay but really what this is about is
booting out the guy after he got exposed
for his failures and cover-up on kovid
and there is a little shot in freud even
if conservatives think
that this me tooing of andrew cuomo is
at least formally just as distasteful
as the metooing of other people the
schadenfreude is really
great for instance when the dems use
these kind of tactics on
brett kavanaugh with far less
credibility to them
andrew cuomo was all for it there is a
disrespect
for women that this administration
chronically
exemplifies after the metoo movement
they did absolutely nothing when it came
to sexual harassment
they have always diminished the charges
of women always consistently
and they're doing it again this
administration is so
terrible to women they
never even compliment the high heels
worn by women around the office they
never
would even greet their secretary with a
nice little kiss just to be polite
they never offer reporters in the room
a nice delicious hot dog and then tell
them they gotta finish it
well well they're watching
they're terrible terrible to women and
so it's wonderful to watch andrew cuomo
kind of squirm even though i think it's
preposterous the way that they're going
after him
this is all about the nursing homes
the real scandal is that andrew cuomo
with the applause of the entire
democratic establishment not just the
elected officials
not even just the bureaucrats and the
activists but the media
as well andrew cuomo's policies were the
absolute deadliest kovid policies in the
entire country
they needlessly killed thousands and
thousands of elderly new yorkers
then he knew about it we now know he
knew about it
because we know that he tried to cover
it up
while he was publishing a book on
leadership lessons from covid19
during all of this democrats had him
speak
at their national convention the the
mainstream media
sexually harassed andrew cuomo for
goodness sakes they should have had some
me too allegations against them they
were so hot for this guy
and now to distract from all of that
and to go after him for a more palatable
reason now we're told it's because he
complimented his secretary or tried to
kiss some girl or something
which inappropriate though it may be
not even in the same stratosphere not
even not even in the same
galaxy from the covid 19 scandal
but because they're masterful machine
politicians in new york andrew cuomo
included
but certainly the state representatives
up in albany
the democratic leaders in new york are
calling for andrew cuomo to resign aoc
kicked this off a little while ago
and you heard some democrats at the
national level start to float this they
say
we need an investigation right they
stopped totally defending cuomo
their crush ended but now
the powers that actually matter the
political pressure in new york
is coming after cuomo and saying hey
buddy you're causing us a whole lot of
headaches
this is not going to work for us anymore
so you need to step down
andrew cuomo remaining defiant
if you want to remain defiant in the
face of
high prices on your auto parts then you
should go check out rockauto.com
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20
years go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same
for professionals and do-it-yourselfers
why on earth
would you spend up to twice as much for
the same parts why on earth would you
subject yourself
to the indignity and degradation of
going into the brick and mortar auto
parts store
and having some punk behind the counter
ask you all these questions about your
car you don't know the answers to
then he goes in the back they never have
the part they order it online probably
from rock auto and then they charge you
twice as much
do not save yourself that humiliation
just go to rockauto.com they've got a
great selection
they've got reliably low prices they
don't have a ton of gimmicks going up
and down you got to order it on tuesday
at two o'clock none of that
and the website is so easy even i can
navigate it
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
then write knowles k-n-o-w-l-e-s in
there how did you hear about us box so
that they know we sent you
the senate majority leader in the state
of new york andrea
stewart cousins is saying what every day
there is another account that is drawing
away from the business of government
we have allegations about sexual
harassment a toxic work environment the
loss of credibility surrounding the
coven 19 nursing home data
and questions about the construction of
a major infrastructure product for the
good of the state
andrew cuomo must resign
pretty there were actually some
misspellings in here because
some of some of these democrats stay
politicians not the brightest bulbs in
the pack
but if you take that aside this is an
absolutely brilliant
political statement here because notice
what she did
it's the sandwich it's the classic
sandwich strategy
of scandals this woman says you know
andrew cuomo he he didn't call his
grandma when he was supposed to call his
grandma
and he was very rude to mrs
bethany across the street and he also
killed thousands of people and covered
it up
and he also didn't show up to church
on sunday at the time that he said he
would and so that's why we need to kick
him out of
the office you say wait what was that oh
yeah i said he didn't show up to church
to the to the
the mass he said he was going to show up
to so no before that
oh yes he gave a really mean look to his
neighbor no after that
oh yeah he killed thousands of elderly
new yorkers and then covered it up and
now there's an fbi or a federal probe
into it
oh that's the scandal right all the rest
of this
was just sort of a sandwich because you
guys don't want to deal with the failure
of your policies not just andrew cuomo's
but
yours broadly you guys were in on this
sort of stuff
state assembly leader in new york
democrat carl heasty says
we have many challenges to address and i
think it is time for the governor to
seriously consider
whether he can effectively meet the
needs of the people of new york
so trump is now or cuomo rather they're
both kind of tough-talking new yorkers
so it's an interesting sort of freudian
slip
cuomo has lost his base of support
who is his support now all the people
propping this guy up so implausibly
have fled him so is cuomo going to
resign
no way cuomo comes out and and he says i
think this is actually a pretty good
defense he says
i was elected by the people of the state
i wasn't elected by politicians
i'm not going to resign because of
allegations the premise of resigning
because of allegations is
actually anti-democratic anybody has the
ability to make an allegation in a
democracy and that's great
but it's in the credibility of the
allegation wow where was this guy during
the kavanaugh scandal huh
where was that wow this andrew cuomo is
pretty level-headed
i actually give him credit for not
stepping down to be clear
andrew cuomo should not be in office
not because he winked at his secretary
but because he killed all the
the elderly new yorkers for the cover-up
the guy
possibly should be wearing an orange
jumpsuit there should at least be a
serious investigation into it
but just as a bare-knuckle political
matter
i i have to give the guy credit for
refusing to resign
because the point he's making is
legitimate
i was not elected by politicians who are
vying and jockeying for power
politicians are also the people who are
making many of these allegations right
i was elected by the people and
resigning over allegations as
anti-democratic i actually sort of agree
with that
in a way we have accountability measures
in this country
they happen at the ballot box now we're
losing election integrity
uh protections which is not good but
i i think that's very important when
the left in this country hated richard
nixon
they got rid of it they tried to get rid
of them at the ballot box
they probably stole the 1960 election
but that's a topic for another day
then they tried to get rid of the ballot
box in 68 didn't work
then they tried to get rid of him at the
ballot box
in 72 doesn't work so what do they do
they get some deep stater to toss him
out of office because
some crook couldn't tape a door
correctly sort of
minor political scandal that both sides
have been doing for a very long time
that is anti-democratic you saw
similar things with trump they try to
beat trump in 2016 it doesn't work so
they just try to throw him out of office
they gin up a bunch of scandals they try
to impeach him they do all this that is
actually
anti-democratic and as we all know from
the washington post
democracy dies in darkness
cuomo has a lot of people furious at him
even on the left
because people don't understand this if
they're not
if they haven't spent some time in new
york and they haven't looked at new york
politics
cuomo is in some ways one of the more
conservative figures in new york he's
still an absolute
horrible leftist who lit the
new york city buildings up in pink when
he could celebrate the expansion of
abortion in that state
right cuomo is a horrible horrible guy
but by new york standards he's actually
somewhat conservative and so a lot of
the leftists in the state
don't really like him very much
teachers don't really let teachers
unions don't really like him very much a
whole lot of forces there
so we'll see how this plays out it's
hard to imagine he survives much longer
like this
but you are noticing the narrative
changing here you're noticing the
narrative about cuomo beginning to
change
you're noticing the narrative more
broadly about kovid changing
the head of the american federation of
teachers randy weingarten
this organization that is doing its
damnedest to keep schools closed in
america
is now trying to change the narrative
speaking with another cuomo fredo cuomo
on cnn
saying what who us no we don't want to
keep the schools closed
no all you got is a big misunderstanding
we're actually
trying to open the schools my union has
been trying to reopen school
since last april we know how important
in-school learning
is but we had a president who refused to
collect data give us the guidance that
the cdc has just given us
and given us the resources these are the
three things and i was on your show
i begged for it for months and months
and months
and ultimately what's happening is that
between
some of the resources we already got in
december which is starting to be out
there
the resources in the rescue act this
vaccine
announcement and the cdc guidance you've
already seen
in the last few weeks a turnaround that
all the school districts
that had closed in november or december
because of the surge
are now reopened so
this defense from the american
federation of teachers
is one of the most outrageous examples
of
gaslighting i've seen in recent years
and we've gotten a whole lot of it
in around the inauguration around the
election around
the entire year of 2020 practically
she says look we want to go back we've
been trying to go back since april
we've just been waiting for guidance
from the cdc
cdc has been issuing guidance i think
the whole time well we've just
because of the bungled covid policies of
trump
trump led the development of a vaccine
in world record time
and got you a vaccine
really before the election but at the
very least we can say within days
after the election the election was in
early november
it's now march
what is the holdup and they say no we
just need more
protections more but we're trying to
reopen
this we're following the science all the
studies show that
the transmission of the virus is not any
higher in schools than it is anywhere
else
all the science shows the kids are not
particularly vulnerable to the thing
well no we're just we're just trying so
hard we're just yeah okay
is it any wonder is it any wonder that
people have no
faith in their elites when we just get
lied to
when we get gaslit by
these sorts of people not just the
electeds that we get gas left by them
but by the media and by union bosses
such as this woman there was just a vote
the la teacher union
just had a vote should we go back to
work
simple enough question 91
of la teacher union members voted not to
go back to work
and the way they're pitching it they say
this vote signals that in these trying
times
our members will not accept a rushed
return
that would endanger the safety of
educators students and families
that's according to the la teacher union
president cecily my art cruz
a rushed return this has been going on
for a year
well we can't it was supposed to be two
weeks uh we can't rush it though
it's been an extra 50 weeks but we can't
we don't want to rush it
it could endanger the safety of students
students
are at statistically zero risk
from this virus the same is basically
true of educators and
families as well but certainly of the
students
statistically like nothing
it raises this question are there any
elites less likable than these
teacher union bosses and they're
actually
the answer to that is yes
princesses and billionaire talk show
hosts
meghan markle sitting down for a
wild interview with oprah which actually
does affect u.s politics it seems like
it doesn't but but it does
ben's going to be talking about this but
first i'm going to be talking about this
because i'm a little more sympathetic to
the crown
than some of my more libertarian pals
over here
at the daily wire and broadly in the
united states i'm i'm more sympathetic
to them
and this meghan markle thing is just so
hideous it exposes not just what's wrong
with british politics
really exposes what's wrong with
american politics
what if the police could go on strike at
a moment's notice
what if firefighters could go on strike
in a moment's notice the military
imagine the kind of disruption and chaos
that would create
these are the dangerous scenarios
associated with public sector unions
in the latest episode of the new series
debunked ben shapiro will break down all
of the known lies and platitudes
that most people are fed with regard to
unions
this latest episode which dropped this
past weekend covers all of that and more
but
here's the but you've got to be a daily
wire subscriber to watch go to
dailywire.com
subscribe use code debunked to get 25
off your new
membership that is code debunked for 25
off at dailywire.com
subscribe we will be right back with a
lot more
there is by my calculation
not a single thing less appealing than
listening to a hollywood actress
complain to a billionaire talk show host
about how hard it was to be
a princess i that is
the actual mathematical perfectly least
likable thing that i think anyone could
possibly do
meghan markle sits down with her poor
poor husband and talks to oprah
about all the dirty laundry
from the royal family there was no
guidance as well right there were
certain things that you couldn't do but
you know unlike what you see in the
movies there's no class on how to
how to speak how to cross your legs how
to be
royal there's none of that training that
might exist for other members
of the family that was not something
that was offered to me so nobody tells
you anything
no nobody prepares you no i mean no but
even sorry but even down to like the
national anthem
no one thought to say oh you're american
you're not going to know that that's me
late at night googling how what's the
i've got to learn this i don't want to
embarrass them i need to learn these
30 hymns for church all of this is
televised we were doing the training
behind the scenes because i just wanted
to make them proud
i just i just wanted to make them proud
and that is why
i'm sitting down with you oprah to say
that these are the worst people on earth
because i'm just
i just care and i want to make them pred
it's just you know it's crazy
all i wanted to do all i wanted to do as
a divorced american actress
was become a princess in another country
and they expect me to learn the national
anthem uh what
is that crazy what what do they think i
have google
what do they what do they think that i
can like look it up that's crazy
i need well actually you know it shut up
shut up harry
s stop it it's just ridiculous
you know i you see am a victim
says the princess
so president trump as always
summed this up a couple of years ago he
was asked about some criticism that
meghan markle had made of him
she was not at that time uh attacking
the
con the government and the royalty of
her adopted
country she was attacking her own
government
and president trump i thought uh had the
most compassionate
and precise take on meghan markle that
one can muster
prince harry and meghan markle uh chimed
in on the u.s election and essentially
encouraged people to vote for joe biden
let me get your reaction to that i'm not
a fan of hers
and i would say this
and she probably has heard that but
i wish a lot of luck to harry
because he's gonna need it
[Laughter]
he's gonna need it that poor guy does
need it this
woman comes in
the reason i mention by the way that
she's divorced is
she is entering into the royal family of
a country with a state
church so it's actually a big problem
and rather than say oh my gosh thank you
for making this exception
i know this is bad i know it's we
shouldn't we shouldn't be doing this
here in the royal family
instead she complains about having to
learn hymns what they expect me to learn
the hymns
because i'm entering into the family
that runs the state church come on
give me a break poor
poor harry so because she doesn't like
it because it turns out that being a
royal
is not just about glitz and glamour and
putting a tiara on because
she found out it actually involves duty
and work you know
very difficult sort of chores like
learning the national anthem of your
country
of your new country because of that she
made her husband leave his family
and abdicate all of his duty all of his
responsibility to the country that had
been so good to him and that he was born
for like no we got to go because i want
to do voice-overs in disney cartoons or
something
so they leave now they're in la they get
to keep a lot of money and poor harry is
just struggling through now they're
attacking his family on television
and the minute he tries to interject she
tells him to keep quiet
but then she talks about real struggles
and this i actually
i don't want to make light of this i
just want to show how perverse our
thinking of this is
as meghan markle says this was so
tough to be a princess that i
contemplated suicide and
she very well may have people in
hollywood are unstable people
generally speaking and maybe she just
couldn't take it maybe she
did not she had a completely different
vision of what it meant to be a royal
maybe she thought it was all about
privilege and not at all about duty and
responsibility
so she was genuinely shocked and she
just couldn't handle it
we had to go to this event and i
remember him saying i don't think you
can go and i said i can't be left alone
because you were afraid of what you
might do to yourself
and we went and that's so sorry to hear
that
and that picture if you zoom in what i
see is how tightly his
knuckles are gripped around mine you can
see the whites of our knuckles because
we are smiling and doing our job but
we're both just trying to hold on
and every time that those lights went
down in that broil box
i was just weeping and he was gripping
my hand and then it was
okay intermission's coming it takes so
much courage to admit that you need help
it takes so much courage to voice that
so
before i criticize what she has to say
here
there is truth to this it does take
courage
to admit when you need help
this is part of the process of
recognizing our own brokenness
in in our human nature right this is
this is a central fact of a christian
life
is having the courage to recognize you
are not perfect that you need
help that you are a miserable sinner and
that you
cannot fix your brokenness on your own
right it's actually a
keen insight and unfortunately in our
now secularized culture
a lot of people don't understand that
and so they're not willing to get help
and that's that's why there actually is
some
legitimately legitimacy to this idea
that we need to
reach out we need to you know muster the
courage to recognize our own inner
problems
sure all true
whether or not going on oprah winfrey's
show
to whine about your husband's family
that you made him
essentially divorce whether that is
helpful to your inner struggle
seems a little dubious to me but the
principle fair enough
there's a flip side though to all this
talk about the courage
to muster the strength to just think
about yourself all the time
the flip side of that is it also takes
courage
to do your duty it also takes courage
to fulfill your responsibilities
to other people and not just yourself
when you marry into the royal family
it's not as though
you know on the fifth date or something
harry sets megan down and says you know
you know love you know the problem i
love
i have something to admit to you i'm a
prince of
england what harry yes uh deary i know
you thought i was a
a motorcycle mechanic but actually i'm a
prince
oh my gosh well we'll make it through
harry well i hope that we can survive
this because i love you
and i had no idea that you were a prince
now i think she knew from the beginning
she just was it would seem only focused
on
the glitz and the glamour and the
privilege of it all but it is a weighty
weighty responsibility
i think too many of our elites forget
meghan markle for a second too many of
our elites don't understand this
they think when you become prominent in
i don't know politics or the media
or this that or the other thing it's
just all about privilege
it's just all about glitz and glamour
they don't want to recognize the duty
and the responsibility
and the gravity and the weight of that
if you forget about being royal where
your entire life
is duty it's why i can't get on board
with the
the kind of conservative american hatred
for the royals you know all the jokes
about the royals
well they live in palaces they have
fancy clothing the
the royals lives are very difficult from
the moment they are born their entire
life
is just about serving the country and
doing whatever the country needs them to
do
and it might seem kind of frivolous
because it's photo ops and it's opening
up different markets and
things like that and welcoming foreign
dignitaries but you
are born into a very specific job with a
ton of media scrutiny
and you can never change it unless you
abdicate
like harry because he met this
american wife unless you abdicate and
bring shame on yourself
you just have to do that job most of us
don't even want to do
the job that we chose for our entire
lives a lot of people
they start doing a job they're like i
kind of want to do something else maybe
they start doing something else
within the broader industry maybe they
switch careers right you don't get to
switch careers
if you're a royal you don't get to just
do whatever you want all the time you
have to focus on that responsibility but
none of our elites
in this country seem willing
to do that takes courage to confront
inner challenges
also takes courage to confront outer
challenges
there are a lot of outer challenges that
require real courage not just looking in
on ourselves so that's important
sometimes
but looking out in this country a huge
one
is that our elites who have taken all
that power feel no responsibility
to our american traditions or the
american people broadly
they consider the american people to be
deplorable irredeemable bitter clinging
rubes and idiots
and neo-nazis who should not be able to
speak in public
up to and including the former president
of the united states
donald trump gave a speech at cpac the
conservative political action conference
where he talked about many of the
problems facing the country
questions about the election what he
might do in 2024
youtube will not permit this video on
the internet
so there was a a channel just
one channel among many posted the video
they had it taken down they were not
not allowed to broadcast it then there
was a question was it just this channel
or is youtube more broadly youtube has
now clarified
they've said that unless users add
countervailing viewpoints about trump's
speech they won't allow trump's speech
up there so for instance
i could play trump's speech right now on
this channel
as long as after he talks i say he's
wrong
he's bad orange man bad if i do that
then i'm allowed to have
trump speech on youtube but if i don't
or if i say yeah well i made some pretty
good points
that video will be taken down youtube
says we enforce our community guidelines
consistently
regardless of speaker or political
leaning they're just as consistent i
think as the washington
post joe biden showers money on
americans
trump braces us all for economic pain
in accordance with our established
presidential election integrity policy
established as of what like five minutes
ago which prohibits content uploaded
after the safe harbor deadline
claiming widespread fraud changed the
outcome of the 2020 us presidential
election
we removed this video from rsbn
they're they're barely even mustering a
justification for this
they never took down any videos of
stacey abrams and other people claiming
that that election was stolen
because stacey abrams is a democrat they
never took down any videos of hillary
clinton
and other prominent democrats claiming
that that election was stolen
after the safe harbor deadline because
those people are democrats
but they will take down any any speech
that they find threatening
to their political agenda from donald
trump or other republicans
because they enjoy the privileges of
being elites and controlling
the flow of information around the
internet but they have no sense
of responsibility to the american way of
life
they actually don't like those american
traditions they want to get rid of those
and institute their own new guidelines
this is
the thesis of my book which i explain
in painstaking detail it's called
speechless controlling words controlling
minds
i i actually do sort of suspect that
this book
is going to face censorship from the
left not because it's some outrageous
raucous shock jock kind of book it's not
at all
but i think that's actually the point
the book very
consistently shows you what the left has
done
how the development of this political
correctness and this censorship
is different than conservatives have
traditionally understood it
and and the book i think explains how if
we if we want to fight it effectively
which we haven't done for now
100 years uh we need to radically change
course
i think they're probably going to go
after that sort of thing so i recommend
you pre-order it by the way
before before they take it down because
the left is now emboldened to use their
privilege to stop
any threats to their rule up to and
including
dr seuss now we we're all joking about
dr
seuss oh my the left is so crazy the
tolerant left is so crazy
that now they're they're taking down dr
seuss books gosh isn't this hilarious
yeah i mean it's
funny i guess it's also very very
dangerous and it makes absolute sense
in the left-wing system now what some
people are going to tell you is well
look
after they took down those dr seuss
books doctors who skyrocketed to the
charts
top of the charts see the free market
wins
no not really sure i guess we're going
to put some more money in the pockets
of the dr seuss publishers who are
censoring him in the first place which
seems kind of crazy to me
but also they're not going to start
publishing the book again
they're just going to squeeze a little
bit more more money out of it at the
very end and then
they're going to continue to censor
those
old beloved books
kevin mccarthy leader in the
uh the republican house right the
minority leader among republicans in the
house of representatives
he decided to go after this kind of
craziness
he was going to read some dr
seuss books on camera green eggs and ham
by dr seuss
i am sam i am sam
sam i am
that's sam i am that sam i am i do not
like
that sam i am do you like green eggs and
ham
i do not like them sam i am i do not
like green eggs and ham
okay you you get the point what's funny
of course is that
senator cruz did this exact thing years
ago i think he i think was like
eight years ago during some of his
absolute wonderful uh performances on
the floor of the senate you know trying
to hold up obamacare trying to hold up
really bad legislation
he uh ted cruz famously read green eggs
and ham so that that's right and
kevin mccarthy clearly has a good taste
in literature i guess
but i i felt this fell flat i'm giving
this as constructive criticism because i
like kevin mccarthy but
i felt this fell flat because the left
is not censoring green eggs and ham
they're not green eggs and amazon is now
at the top of the charts on amazon
but what the left is censoring is a
handful of books the mulberry street
books
a few other dr seuss books that they
feel are racially insensitive
politically incorrect so i looked at
some of the books and i i don't think
they are
there's there's a drawing that's
allegedly racist of a
chinese man and this is very offensive
because he's got a traditional chinese
hat on
or something it's not there's there's
not compared to other dr seuss cartoons
there's nothing offensive
about this cartoon so it seems to me if
we want to fight back against this sort
of thing
it's not that we should read green eggs
and ham we should read that book
right if if our argument really is that
these books these handful of books that
the left is saying are racially
offensive
if we're saying no they're not they're
not everybody needs to get over
themselves and just
not cancel everybody for the slightest
silliest reason
then we should be reading those books
that that would be
much more provocative and i think it
would make a far greater defense but
people don't want to do that because so
many conservatives
i'm not accusing kevin mccarthy of this
might have just been he was reading one
of the most popular
dr seuss books but a lot of
conservatives
will talk a good game on political
correctness but they're not willing to
actually get in there
and determine what things we should say
and what things we shouldn't say this is
another topic i go into
in great detail in my book
i i don't think that the conservative
response to political correctness should
be to say all sorts of terribly
offensive things
i don't think the conservative response
to political correctness is to start
using
the n-word you know all the time in
polite conversation
that's to me that's not i it's maybe
it's politically incorrect to me it's
just
quite rude to do so i don't think the
answer to political correctness is
rudeness i think the answer to political
correctness
is stating things that are perfectly
just true acceptable without
fear of the left-wing mob it's going out
there and saying things like men are not
women
or saying things like i don't know if
you're reading the dr seuss book saying
things like different cultures wear
different
sort of clothing that that sort of thing
is very important
go in there and actually make these
statements but
people don't want to do it they want to
shy away from that sort of thing
meanwhile dr seuss is not the only only
cartoonist under fire
the cat in the hat is not the only
victim of cancel culture
pepe le pew pepe you're you know pepe le
pew he's that sort of girl crazy snake
or a skunk rather from from the old
cartoons pepe le pew
is uh being accused of perpetuating rape
culture according to charles blow at the
new york times
which is on the same tier of journalism
as the washington post
charles blow right some of the first
cartoons i can remember included pepe le
pew
who normalized rape culture blo then
followed this up he said
right-wing blogs are mad because i said
pepe le pew added to rape culture
let's see one he grabs kisses a girl
stranger repeatedly
without consenting against her will she
struggles mightily to get away from him
but he won't release her three he locks
a door
to prevent her from escaping boom there
it is lock him up
lock up that skunk pepe le pew he did it
seems to me no one has ever committed
rape
because a cartoon skunk told them that
it was okay
i'm willing to go out on a limb and say
that
but i actually don't think that that is
why they want to cancel pepe le pew
or any sort of old cartoons
that in any way contradict the
ever-changing dictates of political
correctness i think it's something
deeper than that
i think it's because one the the left
has a point when they talk about
anti-racist babies they actually do have
a point
our brains are forming when we're very
little that's why we educate children
more than we educate adults
because you can shape those brains so so
sure that that matters
also because these cartoons
subtly are questioning the premises of
political correctness
it's exaggerated and sort of ridiculous
with pepe le pew
but what is what is being exaggerated
what's being exaggerated is that men
find women attractive that men and women
are different
they are complementary men
pursue women in a way that women do not
pursue men
because men and women relate to sex and
romance
differently that's the problem that's
what the left doesn't like
that's what is a threat to the left-wing
agenda not because anyone thinks a skunk
is getting people to commit rape
what's offensive in those dr seuss books
well the doctors books are saying
different cultures are different
they have different customs different
traditions it's not all just the same
bland secular liberalism
that's the threat that's the big threat
here
and these are you don't need to defend
uh uh
pepe le pews rape culture to say wait a
second here guys
we need to keep these old cartoons these
old jokes this old
fun because one the these these
jokes this levity this artwork
embellishes life makes it much more
interesting but also because
there are there are some premises in
here and they're deeper and they're
basic and they're absolutely just and
they're absolutely
defensible but our elites
they do not want to do that i don't even
know if they can muster the argument for
that
is there any is there any question why
people are losing faith in their
institutions and their rituals and their
system of government
i don't think it's the people's fault i
think it's the fault
of this desiccated shallow elite
that refuses to take on any sort of
responsibility to the people and when
the elite are not responsive to the
people we hear about this
in the federalist papers then society
starts to
break down let's see if we can build it
back up i'm michael knowles the michael
knowles show
see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 today on the
ben shapiro show megan markel accuses
the royal family
of racism joe biden blows out the
spending with a 1.9 trillion dollar bill
and the media insists that censorship is
in censorship
so long as the stuff being censored is
the stuff they don't like that's today
on the ben shapiro show give it a listen